late last year Alibaba co founder Jack
Ma was confirmed as an official member
of the Chinese Communist Party Jack Ma
also happens to have a not very
communist sounding estimated net worth
that peaked at 50 billion dollars in
2018 even though China remains
officially committed to a communist
future with equality for all and wealth
distribution based on need its history
of capitalistic compromise has made it
the place to turn personal millions into
billions this is your bloomberg quick
take on China's billionaires by one
estimate China creates a new billionaire
every two days the seeds of the
billionaire boom were planted four
decades ago beginning in 1978 when
Communist Party patriarch dung Xiao ping
opened the country up to private
enterprise and investment since then
China began shifting away from
agriculture and increased its focus on
manufacturing eventually leading to
growth that turned the country into the
world's second largest economy behind
the u.s. there's been this discussion of
what is socialism was capitalism but
they're not is there not poverty the
lines between business and politics have
become increasingly hazy as President Xi
Jinping has led a campaign to ensure the
Communist Party plays a leading role in
all aspects of society the sort of
shining example of what China hopes it
can become which is you know cutting
edge you know smart people doing cool
things and making products the people
around the world want to use their a lot
but China hasn't given up on communism
it just made full communism a goal with
no time frame on the roadmap to
communism the country will have to
become fully socialist first which she
has set a goal of reaching by 2035 China
is a communist country
it's a one-party state so in that sense
is very intensely focused on making sure
it can maintain control at the expense
of a lot of civil rights and sort of
other
you know freedoms occupations Jack Ma
was among 100 people honored by the
Communist Party as part of the
celebration marking 40 years of China's
economic reform evidence that on the
issue of communism China is more than
content to wait
you